yeah hello and welcome to this video I
know it's in the middle of everything
but somehow my recording software
crashed so and this is a planet fun game
so I want to not lose it entirely check
check check yeah you haven't seen the
most interesting part but i will show
you i'm sorry that this is not a full
complete game but my recording software
i had problems i actually the game
before that didn't record it all and
this is now only the end of it I'm sorry
about that but it was really a pretty
cool game so let's let's have a revenue
so to say I'm sorry then it was alive I
don't know what happened down yeah my
opponent played this funky like beef I
if that's a move that is sometimes seen
if you have a have a pawn on d4 instead
of the knight on f3 yeah I've never saw
never seen it I decided to just stop the
pawn and then he played a 6 which I
answered with age three I don't know
this is probably not the best move but I
thought it it's funny preventing Bishop
g4 yeah ID I expected 90 form that looks
like a more normal move and he went back
yoke a 26 now and played for this weird
structure and the center which gives me
some attacking ideas yeah you five i
think is right returning something and
now he went nights c5 which seems very
risky I went night g5 just to check here
okay he took like g6 yeah and now I win
age four and he played Bishop e7 and the
question now is can I take on age 7 or
not I decided to do that the engine
gives Queen g3 just form a big advantage
without sacrifice
okay well I felt that this is just too
interesting to not do now my h porn is
running and he is in this pin so what
other way around rather and it doesn't
really it's not easy to do this and this
for example here I have for the check
but i also have aged six and i'm going
to promote you cannot go here because
the hookah saying obviously so 97 makes
it the only move so aged six yeah and
now he went 9 f8 it's funny how the
engine gives this position as roughly
equal at the moment but I think a couple
of deeper calculation will probably give
a more a clearer picture I'm not really
sure to trust the engine here because I
mean it gives black a slight advantage
which it's not quite clear what this
means yeah d for the d4 should loosen
sierra after age 7 i'm winning I thought
he has to put put the rook here and then
I thought a g4 g5 was was my boss my my
plan now here maybe am this is so yeah
this is a completely a completely murky
position this is what the engine is
giving slight edge for black so it's
it's a total mess he went deform age
seven and here we are after Bishop
Bishop g5 is end of game he has no
defense check check check check yeah and
he result can only give me a give me
more material um yeah so I was a nice
one yeah and fortunately the game before
that also didn't record um
I don't know what to make of this what I
can't do this um I just treat this as a
bonus in a way here this was the game
before and it was pretty cool against
Grand Master shadow call there was a
rare line of the wheel when we quickly
got into this ending and yeah black has
the worst pawn structure he's got the
double pawn here and I have a clean pawn
structure on the King side this should
give white a very very small advantage
it is not really that significant but a
little bit and I think however how the
way she went I just tried everything and
black is probably ok but I think he
probably tried a bit too hard to do
something the c-4 approach I'm not sure
about from here the computer likes my
position and chat yeah right that's
probably not that great then the engine
was to do this which looks better really
you have to say sometimes you need to be
a bit skeptical still about the ending
abilities of the computers sometimes
it's weird what they do in there in the
absolute majority of cases the computer
is playing the endgame well nowadays but
sometimes they are still real situations
yeah here I think he probably check here
this kind of stuff is probably over
doing it from here brother why this
matter and we had a big scramble at
least I had some time left yeah I wasn't
I wasn't struggling timewise yeah yeah
he here he is China but check check he
gave me that pawn and he has to
recapture which is it seems leading to a
draw check but this is probably losing
and the good thing for me was that one
almost always only moves and I didn't
screw it up it was just one move I could
play here made a mistake though and here
I should teach at and then aged 6 is
strong he has to go to you 492 Bishop
somewhere and here this is a very
typically computer type of ending purely
tactical now the pony is covered because
of this tactic chat now shine white
white wins yeah in the game up like this
and here he probably can hold he took
this King c3r stepped out of the out of
the pin and night and therefore not sure
not sure we can still hold a gym let's
go forward a little bit yeah so from
here it's losing king of six where king
of six is a draw he's covering this the
only way forward would be to get a night
to be seven words it's difficult he went
they are key at no time so now it is a
win king c7 son it's the same thing just
not not too too quick here if you like
this this if you start with this move we
can we can still sacrifice yeah okay
sorry for this is kind of weird video
with the end
Game and then a summary of the other but
it was I think here it was an
interesting ending um yeah it would have
been cool to have the other game game
life completely with some of my
recording software I had a headache
hiccup ok guys thanks for watching
anyway